just before Christmas the president made
the decision to end America's troop
presence in Syria his rationale was
simple we were there to defeat Isis Isis
has been crushed time to declare victory
and go home makes sense no not in
Washington people here lost control
America is not allowed to withdraw from
any place ever wherever American troops
go they must remain until the end
whatever that is well there's so many
foolish things this man has done but
this ranks pretty high a decision that
is dangerous and a decision that is a
Christmas present
divide American giving a huge Christmas
present to Putin and to Iran I couldn't
disagree more with this decision it's a
terrible decision I think this will be
considered one of the worst foreign
policy blunders of this century these
people are too dumb to govern but their
governing nonetheless they will get
their way potentially despite the fact
none of them is present only the
president decides what our troops do but
they may win recently Senator Lindsey
Graham of South Carolina boasted that
the president had been convinced to
pause the withdrawal of American troops
from Syria no doubt the next objective
is making that pause permanent what next
Douglas McGregor watches carefully he's
retired he was army colonel all through
the terrific book margin of victory he
joins us tonight colonel thank you very
much for coming on so if you believe in
civilian control the military it should
be as simple as the president saying
this is what we're going to do but it
doesn't seem to be that simple
no I think there's a problem and we've
got to remember that most of your senior
officers are products of the Clinton
Bush Obama era so they have a lot
invested in this and remember that the
people who live in the 7zip codes in and
around Washington DC have all become
millionaires as a result of their
investment in these failed operations
that's not talking about that's
literally true yes of course so you put
the two together and you have a lot of
resistance to ending something that's
being profitable for them it hasn't been
profitable for the American people it's
been a disaster trillions of dollars in
debt over the last 17 years thousands of
people killed and wounded and for what
the answer is not much it just seems
like if you're looking for a crisis a
constitutional crisis or something that
would undermine
democracy as we practice it for 240
years it's the idea of unelected the
unelected subverting the power of the
elected right I mean isn't that
democratic by definition the problem is
though the unelected are being supported
by many of the elected to obstruct this
decision to leave there's another reason
for this in addition to the problem with
money historically when we leave as we
did when we left Vietnam right we're out
permanently
yeah people know once we leave Syria
once we get completely out of Iraq once
we get completely out of Afghanistan
it's over and President Trump is going
to do that that's very clear this pause
is just that it is a pause we had to get
out of northern Syria quickly and the
reason for that is simply there were
tens of thousands of Turkish troops
poised to attack the Kurds the
terrorists who have been attacking
Turkey in northern Syria we got the
Syrian government to go in there we got
out now we have created an enormous
problem for mr. Putin because mr. Putin
has cultivated the Turks mr. Putin has
also cultivated his Iranian and Syrian
allies he's got to make a choice does he
allow the Turks into Syria then he loses
his position with the Syrians and the
Iranians
so the notion that mr. Putin has somehow
another one something is absurd this has
been a very clever move on the part of
the president so if you see like six or
seven senators and talking heads in a
row repeating the same talking point
like robots this is a Christmas present
for Putin right that's like prima facie
evidence that they're dumb right well
you could say stupid but obviously
they're briefed by only one side and
that side has no interest in the truth
the truth is that by getting out of the
way we have eliminated the consensus it
was holding these various diverse
partners together there is no reason why
the Turks the Russia in this Iran ian's
should cooperate at all and that's a
good thing it is a good thing colonel
thank you very much good to see you